hey guys what's up this is andrew for
consensus.com
so as you can see i am not in hong kong
yet i am guys stuck
in istanbul for two days already and i'm
leaving tonight i had some issues with
the translation
of my kobe test it was in french and
they wanted
it to be in english or chinese otherwise
they can't understand it that's what i
said
so anyway i got rejected for my flight
to hong kong and i'm gonna
fly tonight no movie i hope so
actually it's not that bad you know
istanbul is a beautiful place so i could
take some time to visit the city
and it is marvelous so in the end this
event is not so bad but
i need to update you guys we are right
now
monday morning here so i'm making some
videos
on amc i hope i'm gonna have some time
to make some on gme
on bitcoin on tesla you know there is a
lot of stocks i want to update you guys
on
so i'm gonna start with amc and see what
happened last week and what are the
different scenarios for the coming week
let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so as usual i'm gonna start
by reminding you
what i was saying in my last video so in
my last video i had different scenarios
i had here
a triangle potential triangle a b
c d e so it could have been like this
it was like that a b
c and i was waiting for d e and then you
know my fifth wave all right so this one
is of the table
i had a mobulish no and this was my most
bullish scenario and
my alternative scenario was the wxy but
that is happening here so i told you
guys that we might go to the 37 38 area
i was basically saying 37 but showing
you 38.9 i think
so sorry i was not very clear of course
the level
i wanted to talk about was actually even
a bit higher it was the bottom of the w
wave so it was around 39 you know but
it's always an area here you have 37.5
here you have 35.5 so it's all this area
so
you never know where it's going to
rebound exactly now we know 38.7
and we completed the wxy correction
with a strong very very strong rebound
evolving a lot of volume guys the
highest volumes we saw
in the past week i would say and we had
a rebound of around 25
then slightly corrected so from here
what are the different scenarios that we
might have as you can see i have already
drawn my preferred scenario which is
that finally this false wave is complete
once again guys i want to show you
quickly the situation this
is i think what we're having look guys
so this is you know the elliott wave
theory book you just type earlier to a
theory
written by frost impressed on google and
you're gonna find this link in the first
three links
then here you tap triple three you know
i'm just doing it with you so you can do
it yourself and here we go guys so
elliot explains that
false waves of second waves you know
corrective waves sometimes
are not single abcs there are
combinations of those corrective
patterns in moving flats
zigzags triangles and even sometimes
ending diagonals which is a multi weight
and in this situation look guys looks
like this
really reminds us of amc correction
we have a b c flat then
w x y a zigzag so this is like
you know between our two threes and then
the second three
which is not triangle in our case no
sorry it's this one it's flat
uh zigzag and zigzag all right look
look guys so this is an elliot wave book
once again
so flat
okay then
zigzag and typical zigzag guys
so this is a typical corrective
pattern now once again this was not my
preferred scenario
and i was telling you so basically that
below the 48 level which is here which
was the lower band of my triangle
i would be bearish on the short term and
that i would
see the 3738 area revisited which
happened actually here but what is
interesting to notice guys and i really
want to discuss this with you
it's important because you know amc is
very tough guys to analyze let's be
honest let's be honest because here
what we had i remind you guys what i was
seeing here and this is the reason why i
told you that
after you know the shop loss we had on
the 2nd of july
then we had the strong rebound so what i
was seeing guys
here sorry it was before actually here i
didn't have this divergence
but here i had a divergence and it's
very funny to see
you know between here and here you can
see that the market is making
higher lows from the w wave the bottom
of the w wave and you know the 52 level
we had here then we had this rebound
and the momentum indicator was shifting
down
and as you can see here i have my
magnets so i have one low here and i
have a lower low so this
is a bearish divergence so i had this
one the bullish hidden divergence
the momentum indicator was shifting
lower and the market was making higher
lows
and still we didn't have guys the strong
move
up that i was expecting so it's very
interesting to analyze what happened so
first we can see that we have
divergence here but it's not perfect all
right it's not perfect you can see that
here
the market is not rebounding you know as
beautifully as it should in
the theory all right here you can see
that the momentum is rebounding
stronger and of course if you wait for
this
strong rebound of the momentum probably
the price action would be much higher
ready so that's why it's very
interesting
to try to enter to use these signals
very early because they are early
signals and if you use them early you
have
an advantage compared to the other
techniques so i like to use this and i
can tell you that usually when i see
that
the market is rebounding now do we have
that
i don't want to scare you guys but this
is my alternative scenario today i'm
going to come back to it
very soon did we have it on the hourly
time frame it's very interesting to
notice as well
from here for example to here so this is
another one okay i'm checking another
one
and here you see that we don't have it
all right the momentum indicator is not
going lower
when the market is making higher lows so
it's always interesting to
see you know if you have it on the audi
or on the flowers
once again i'm gonna explain this very
carefully guys in the course i'm
preparing
here you should not use the hourly
divergence to spot this kind of move
because you can see guys
we have too many waves one two three
four
four waves it's a bit too much you know
if you have three is fine
okay two is perfect for example here we
had two but the second
wave was not rebounding strongly i'm
talking here about the blue line which
is the macd
so you use the max indicator the blue
line is the macd the orange line is the
exponential moving average of the magnet
itself
and the signal of the magnitude which
i'm not using here at all is
the difference between those two lines
i'm only here using the blue line which
is the macd which i use
as a momentum indicator to spot
divergences
so basically what i wanted to show you
guys here
is that even when we have a bullish
hidden divergence that is beautiful you
know on the four hours time frame that's
you know to me almost perfect
we still managed to break
here this level guys and to go to 37 all
right
with very strong moves down so what is
this telling me
i don't like to talk about market
manipulation because
it sounds like you know a small group of
people can
actually control amc price no one can
control amc's price
no one right you know it's a free market
and this stock is just following
you know the usual demand and offer
mechanisms but
here when i see this kind of behaviors
what is this telling me is that some
people
might actually agree between each other
to take one action here selling together
and i think that this is what happened
guys because why
didn't these people you know a
divergence is telling you that when the
momentum is going lower the sellers are
taking ground why didn't they take more
ground here
at the 52 level here when i where i had
my divergence on the first time frame
why the market didn't go down here why
did it go down
here so maybe there was some news maybe
you know stuff like this
you know once again i'm on holiday so i
don't have time to check everything but
from what i see the sellers just are
well organized
and they decided to all sell together so
whatever but
i just wanted to point this out to tell
you guys that we need to be very
very careful on amc when we see those
kind of divergences
because even if you have the divergent
signal
then maybe you can realize that actually
the sellers were hidden
and they're gonna once again act all
together and
make amc price shift lower which
happened
here now i'm gonna come back guys to
what you wanna know
in this video i'm gonna give you my
different scenarios so basically my
preferred scenario is that the wxy is
complete once again i showed you guys
that it's really looks like the example
of the books there are not many examples
guys there are like two examples
actually have
this one this one and then somewhere you
have a real market example so basically
you have two or three
examples and you can see that amongst
those two or three i found amc's
one so here if this is complete we're
gonna have
here the fifth wave starting so
one two three four five you know
something like this
i don't want to talk about levels here
but you know my level is 130 maybe 100
only
i'm gonna update you guys while we go
there but for now this is only one two
what you guys want to see
what you absolutely want to see guys
is a break of this trend line all right
a breakout of this trend line that is
here
so we see it better on our little frame
here guys
okay for this scenario to happen we need
to break
this trend line so right now the level
is around 48 once again 48 guys this
level is important
it was the breakup level here and it
might be
again the breakout level but of a
different trend line the trend and i
have connecting here the highs
you know the yellow one this one so
basically what you are looking for guys
is something like this as usual
we break it we re-test and we go higher
all right so you wait and you buy the
re-test if you want to enter this trade
as
we should do all right so this is my
first scenario and then we're gonna have
a one two three four five going higher
but i need to tell you something is that
you know there are
alternative scenarios that we need to
take into account as well
here triple three all right
so you can see that you have a double
three which i just
showed you guys so w x y but you can
have w
x y x z so something like this
so it's possible as well that we get two
more corrective patterns right
so maybe an x or something like this
abc and a last abc
or maybe triangle maybe triangle you
know triangles are often
the last wave
so i'm waiting for this triangle
actually you know i'm waiting for this
triangle when i'm going to see this
triangle i would be very confident that
the fixed wave is starting
so this is my second scenario is that we
have um w x y x
z and then we go higher and i need to
tell you that we have an alternative
scenario that is ugly guys but
i don't want to blind my eyes and
quicken it so we're gonna have a look at
that scenario
to do that we're gonna invert the charts
and we're gonna try to imagine
because i i like to invert the charts
because i'm used to see stocks going
higher so i don't wanna get some
psychological biases
thinking you know that everything goes
up so i'm just inverted the chart and i
try to see
when i would enter this trade in a
buddhist case
so this would mean that basically we had
a trip so let me invert
again sorry i did it too early so here
you know i have my third wave
false wave at the beginning i was
telling you that this is a false wave so
maybe the x
wave here is a truncated fifth once
again guys
you can find everything you need about
truncated fields
here all right i'm not gonna go through
this here but basically a truncation
you know is when the market fails to do
the fifth wave all right
so basically you have one two three four
and the five is not
going higher than the fourth wave so
this could be a few spectrum getting
fifths
so then if this is a truncated fifth
it means that here we would have a one
two three four five
starting all right it looks like this
all right two three
four and five okay so now let me invert
again
so we have this ugly alternative
scenario
but we need to be prepared for it so
guys what you want to see once again
i show you guys here that we rebounded
exactly
guys on this trend line here is acting
as a resistance so we have a double
resistance
here and here so
now that it's the same level around 50
level you know
48 would be probably on monday session
at the open so this this is the level
with where the false wave rebounded
so here we might have uh you know a
fifth wave starting
on the downside and if we do guys what
is the level that
would tell us that this is starting it
would be this level guys all right so
basically the 45 level so you can use
here either a trend line like like this
okay you have many things here actually
you know
let me go in the 30 minutes time frame
on the 30 minutes time frame you have
this
50 moving average that is here roughly
uh you have this trend line you have the
45 level so basically all this area
between 45
and 46 is the area that is telling us
that the fifth wave of the
alternatives ugly scenario is not
happening
so as long as we are above that we are
safe and once again guys
even in this situation it's important
that you know just don't panic because
look imagine we have this
ugly scenario what would that happen as
usual guys
okay if this is meant to go higher which
means as i inverted the scale that amc
would go over
okay here maybe we completed this one
two three four five in yellow and we had
the trinket fifths
you know the scenario would be like this
um um
okay no more w x y sorry and then
if this happens guys what can we say we
can say
one thing for sure is that this is a one
so we're gonna have a two right and i
don't want to talk about anything else
but
i just want you to tell you guys that
anyway we would have a re-test of the 37
38 area even if you go to 24 so 24 is an
amazing level to buy if we go there
and probably if we go there guys this
would be ugly we would then
i don't imagine that after going to 24
we strongly rebound all right this would
maybe be the end of
amc but we are far far far from it guys
for now but
i just need to update you about
everything and once again
here guys look at this false wave you
know
it's for those who are watching my video
for some time you are used to know
you and you know that false waves are
usually zigzags flat
triangles you know stuff like this stuff
that is like you know consolidation
this is not a typical force wave at all
guys this is not
even a zigzag i don't know how to label
this stuff
to me like yeah things are not this way
um
more like this all right so i think that
amc
would break the 48 area that we're gonna
have the retest of this area and that
we're gonna start
the fifth wave finally and go to the 135
area all right guys so that's it for me
i hope you enjoyed this video i hope i
managed to explain to you how i build up
my different scenarios what techniques i
like to use what are divergences why
divergences sometimes are
tricky to use on you know stocks that
train because some people
said that the volume is lower uh the
volume is very big guys around 6 billion
usd trading every day on amc
so it's like you know 23 percent of the
market capitalization it's a lot guys so
amc is still very hard
and that's why sometimes it's tricky to
analyze the stock because you have so
strong volumes coming
and if you know sellers organize
then of course they're gonna manage to
take some ground like they did last week
but
buyers are better organized guys so i'm
not worried too much about that i think
we're gonna
finally go to the 125 area very soon
so if you enjoyed this video please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys